hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar molecular guided hi plex spatial
profiling in the tumor micro-environment
i am michelle ashton of labyrinth and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by advanced cell diagnostics and
nano string technologies to learn more
please visit www.azpbs.org/horizonte is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send will answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the support tab sound at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen this presentation is
educational and this offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credit
I now present today's speakers anouska
anushka addicted and application
scientists at advanced cell Diagnostics
Doug Heiner Feld a principal product
application scientist at nano screwing
technologies Chris Merrett a senior
scientist at in fam'ly string
technologies for a complete biography on
our speakers please visit the creepy
Java at the top of your screen our
speakers will now begin their
presentations
Thank You Michelle this is Doug hehner
Feld from nano string technology and
just to go over the agenda for the
presentation today we're going to start
by talking about the significance of
spatial profiling with high flexing
capabilities I'll give an introduction
to the DSP technology and the new code
will give an introduction to the RNA
scope technology will then talk about a
detailed workflow for molecular guided
spatial analysis compatibility and
correlation between the two platforms
and how you can use RNA scope to confirm
results that you identify with the geo
mix digital spatial profiler
so going back a few years Merck
convinced on this study shown here it
was published here in the journal of
clinical investigations and they were
focused on identifying a signature that
could predict therapeutic response to
the immune checkpoint inhibitors and to
do that they did extracted RNA from FFP
samples in Rhianna nana string gene
expression hi clex
a say and what they identified was an 18
gene signature which they call the GE P
which we tend to refer to as the tumor
inflammation signature is tist
so in that graph on the bottom right you
see in the upper right hand quadrant
patients samples that have high tumor
inflammation scores on the x-axis and
have very good survival PFS on the
y-axis the conundrum though is you also
see patients in the bottom right where
they have high levels of inflammation
but they don't respond so the
inflammation itself can be predictive
but there's still a gap and the clinical
utility of that si
they've been followed this up with
additional studies where in addition to
doing the tumour information signature
they added tumor mutation burden as well
again to see if they could better
predict respond to the single agent and
you checkpoint inhibitors
so just focusing on the melanoma on the
right and these results you see on the
y-axis tumor mutation burden so patients
that are high for tumor mutation burden
and then on the x-axis the P is or GP
score and then that upper right-hand
corner in melanoma you see that 57% of
the patients that are high for both
tumor mutation burden and T is respond
to the therapy
you
the conundrum in being is that they're
still 43% of patients wear these types
of molecular analyses are not able to
predict whether or not those patients
are going to respond
that really comes down largely to the
challenge of heterogenous tissues so
doing bulk analysis as you see on the
left and looking at responders and
non-responders
when looking at bulk sample you can
oftentimes see very similar patterns of
expression however if you're able to go
in and target very specific regions of
the tumor perhaps in the infiltrated
regions or MU deserts and focus just on
those you can then start to reveal
interesting biology that would actually
then be predictive of therapeutic
response
so on the left side there's technology
such as nano string for very
quantitative high Plex bulk gene
expression assays and then on the right
side there's very good technologies for
spatial imaging to get great
visualization and importantly you retain
the morphological context of the tissue
so this partnership between the industry
and a CD really seek to integrate these
two technologies so you have the Geo mix
digital spatial - profiling which is a
spatial high Flex profiling technology
that I'll be talking about in more
detail and then you have RNA scope which
is a single cell resolution gene
expression technology very high
sensitivity and very specific so
integrating these together where you can
use RNA scope for molecularly guided ROI
selection going to G omics using that
RNA scope result to identify regions of
interest and then doing high plex
profiling of those and ultimately going
back in and doing single-cell
confirmation by RNA scope ish technology
and so I'm going to turn it over to
anushka now he's going to tell you more
about the RNA scope technology
thank you Doug for those of you who are
not familiar with our little technology
we are an in situ hybridisation acid
that were specifically designed to
overcome many of the limitations of our
traditional ish ethic while still
maintaining high sensitivity and
specificity of detection this technology
consists of three major parts as you see
on the screen the first part is a probe
design where an ACD will specifically
design a target probe against your gene
of interest the second part is a signal
amplification strategy we have a unique
signal amplification strategy that
ensures very high signal-to-noise ratio
and lastly our detection and
qualification strategy which allows you
to see a single molecule of RNA as a
nice punctate dot and this is available
in both fluorescent as well as
commercial expect on the actually allows
for spatial mapping of mRNAs long
non-coding RNAs price variance highly
homologous sequences politicians and as
I mentioned before can be visualized in
both fluorescent and chromogenic
spectrum this after is widely applicable
to different types of sample we can use
this on as a PD tissue on sixth frozen
samples fresh frozen samples cultured
cells and PBMC
as I mentioned the Arnett core
technology has been used for the
detection of a variety of different
targets with spatial resolution some of
the more specific examples include
detection of highly homologous sequences
like the series our three point is our
vector G TCR and secreted protein Arnett
cope has this widely applied and used
for the confirmation of single-cell RNA
seek data has been used in combination
with development and the technology has
been applied across vast number of
research areas which include basic
science research infectious disease
research cancer and clinical research as
well as biopharm art discovery and
development now let's go in a little bit
more detail to understand what makes any
scope a unique in situ hybridization
tickling the two major key aspects of
this technology are the probe design and
the signal amplification strategy what
shown on screen is our probe depicted as
easy to really tell you the different
parts of this probe let's focus on the
bottom portion of this probe which is
your target binding sequence as the name
suggests it is the complementary
sequence specifically designed against a
target of interest and will bind on your
target gene the top portion is the
preamplifier binding region which
follows the basis of the signal
adjudication tree development and the
middle portion is the linker region
which connects these two portions of the
probe now when do we probe bind in
tandem to address the sequences on your
target transcript it forms a lead pair
now this is significant because your
preamplifier will come and bind until is
repair on your target early and this the
amplifier funds far off on the
foundation of your signal amplification
tree once the preamplifier is bound
number of amplifier molecules will come
and bind onto the sea and the
which allows for the binding of loyalty
level or chroma sonically labeled fruit
now this will give a highly amplified
signal which allows for detection of
even though really low expressing Target
or GG now this is also sensitivity of
our technique what about the specificity
well unless LD pair is bounced in tandem
to a target early the preamplifier
cannot bind onto those each probe for
example acid binds not specifically to
another target gene the preamplifier
cannot state we bind to a single vPro I
will rat there is no tree building and
no signal detection so this technology
ensures high sensitivity and specificity
of signal detection now when we design a
probe against your target of interest we
design it as a fool proof of 23 spares
these 23 pairs bind next to each other
on your target a filter but for any kind
of signal to be visible we need at least
three bills or three Z pairs to bind to
your target of interest
in this next slide I'm going to
elaborate a little bit about the product
line that we offer or we offer any scope
as part of manual as a all on automated
platform in the manual si we have chrome
Jenna cafe and sourcing si in cryogenic
assays we have the Cineplex assays and
we also have the duplex I think
available and different of the
chlorogenic type in the multiplex assays
of certain IP we currently have an assay
that can detect up to four target genes
on the same sample and this can be done
on SPE to shoot six chosen and fresh
frozen samples like I mentioned we
provide assays that are supported by the
Leica and Ventana automated systems
another active that we provide is the
base code pathway which is a suture
assay for the early scope acid and it's
specifically designed to detect short
artists spike variants and poignant
ations now the unique thing about this
assay is that it can discern up to a
single base pair difference and can be
very significant when you are looking at
for mutations in cancer research or
force work early detection in
neurobiology and not pleased we recently
launched our high flex tours with ethics
which can now detect up to 12 targets on
the same sample and can be very useful
when samples are in limited supply we
can do to advocacy on six frozen and
fresh frozen samples
now coming back to our joint workflow we
will now learn how to on x50 and RNA
scope can work together to provide
especially result high flex analysis I
will now hand over the platform to Doug
who will explain the zoom XP XP
technology in detail
thanks Anushka
so on the left side importantly we have
the reagent so these are the reagents
that allow us to profile large numbers
of proteins or genes in spatial context
on tissue so just focusing on the
protein for a minute so what we do is we
take a validated antibodies that are
specific to the target that we're
interested in analyzing in the tissue
and we conjugate to that a UV photo
cleavable linker so every antibody gets
you need DNA algo nucleotide with this
photo cleavable linker conjugated to it
the same is true for the RNA probes so
we take ish probes the each probe we
conjugate a unique photo cleavable
linker what that allows us to do is
again back to the protein take a bunch
of different validated antibodies each
with a unique linker pull them together
stain the sample and then it's ready to
go into the geo mix platform the geo mix
platform essentially is a microscope and
it has a unique ability to shine UV
light exactly where you wanted within
the tissue and only where you shine the
light are those tags released those tags
are then collected and analyzed in a
spatially distinct way as shown in the
data on the right where you're looking
at the expression of the different
antibodies the different markers in the
panel across these different distinct
locations within the tissue
you
so preparing a sample for 4G omics is
very straightforward for protein it's
essentially the same as
immunohistochemistry and for RNA
analysis the same is in situ
hybridization so we combine two
different reagents what this is showing
here on the left is the imaging reagent
so these are RNA scope probes targeted
to genes of interest and then you
combine those with the profiling
reagents which are the DNA bar-coded ish
probes that are used for the encounter
or geo mix readout once you've stained
the sample it is ready to go or into the
system
you
so on the left is the the Geo mix
platform itself is a four channel
fluorescent microscope so the slides are
inserted into the system if in images it
for whatever channels you're using you
then use that image to define regions of
interest throughout the tissue once
that's done the system shines the UV
light only on those regions of interest
one at a time so it shined the light
dips up the tags fix the tags from that
specific region of interest deposits it
into a plate goes to the next region of
interest shine the light sets up the
tags puts it in the plate so it goes
around and around very quickly in cycles
through the image then profiles each
region of interest that plate and comes
off the instrument and gets hybridized
to our encounter barcodes which I'll
talk about in a minute where each of
those UV cleavable barcodes are actually
counted and enumerated
so how do we count these molecules so
this uses the really the
bread-and-butter nana string bar coding
chemistry on the Left we have a capture
present on the right we have a reporter
probe in the middle are these half site
each of these half sites are
complementary to a very specific
sequence so if that sequence is present
in this in the sample when we hybridize
it together it forms this complex
complex and then that complex is read
out the encounter platform so you'll see
in this case this sequence that you're
hybridizing the captcha probe in the
barcode to is in fact this photo Creed
linker that's in the well of that plate
from the system
once we've done the hybridization we run
it on the encounter the encounter is
also a microscope and it images and
takes pictures of these barcodes and
simply counts them so every time a
particular protein was present in the
sample its barcode was present were
reading the barcode and then we know
that that protein was expressed at that
particular location
so a really simple example of that to
give you a feel for how it works so here
we have lymphoid tissue its stained with
a collection of DNA barcoding antibodies
and at the same time staying with both
ki-67 in c d3 fluorescent antibodies we
image it on the system we didn't select
regions of interest so in ROI 5 you see
here that is an area that is
fluorescently very strong 46 b7 and the
DNA barcode and antibody for ki-67 then
shows up by reading the digital counts
shown on the y-axis the same is true in
roi 9 but for CD 3 but remember we're
standing with many more DNA barcoding
antibodies in this case which you don't
see at this level but once we count
those you then see and are able to
quantitate the expression of all the
different markers that are in the panel
that you're using so you can see on the
y-axis the different antibodies that
were analyzed in the different regions
of interest and you can see how they
cluster together in two very distinct
and heterogeneous profiles
so another really unique aspect of this
technology is the ability to exquisitely
control wear on the tissue you shine
that UV light and the way we do that is
we've incorporated a digital micromirror
device so each one of these little
independently controlled mirrors is
about a micron square in size and what
that allows you to do is to shine the UV
light onto that digital micromirror
device and it shapes it onto the tissue
so in this example we've stained with
pants.i de keratin and then DNA and blue
and we create a mask so all regions that
are positive for seeing pancetta keratin
and we shine the light there we then
turn around and shine the light just on
the pancetta carat or negative region so
essentially what we've done is optical
micro dissection of the tissue in this
sort of organic phenotype driven way
so going beyond that one approach this
allows you a lot of flexibility and how
you interrogate the sampled with spatial
resolution so you can do simple
geometric ROI looking at regions of
interest perhaps infiltrated tumor
tumors or immune deserts and this is a
method that's been very successful we've
had a number of very high-profile papers
already published using that approach
you can also do the segmentation like I
just described focusing just on pancetta
carrots and positive or pan size of
carrots and negative as an example the
rare cell application is an excellent
application when you really know a
specific cell type you're interested in
profiling so for example you might be
standing for cd68 and then the dark
cells here would be to cd68 positive
cells you would shine the light and
profile only those cd68 positive cells
and then you can profile the cd68
negative cells or the white cells it
does all of those cells at the same time
so that digital micromirror device
allows you to shine the light only on
those dark cells and then we're also
minimally on the white cells in there
else contour profiling is another
application that's been interesting both
in cancer but also there's been a lot of
interest in this in the context of
neurobiology and what this allows you to
do is essentially profile the tissue
different distances from some biological
structure a cellular structure of
interest so it could be a invasive
margin or something like that and then
the gridded profiling is an application
where you know you really want to just
uncover the heterogeneity expression of
all the markers in the panel across the
tissue so it's a much less targeted
approach but a great way to discover the
heterogeneity of expression of say being
you and landscape within the tissue
all of this is really integrated into an
excellent very easy-to-use
integrated software solution so on the
left you have the control center that's
what allows you to do the imaging or
scanning of the tissues select your ro
eyes initiate your collections once
that's done and you have that plate
that's hybridized some banana string
barcodes that then goes out to the
encounter for counting that data then
comes right back in to the geo mix data
analysis software shown in the upper
right where you then retain the
Association of the images the regions of
interest the probes and the final data
in data visualization all of the same
software
you
and its built-in in a cloud architecture
so while it runs on this system
anybody from their computer can
essentially go to Google Chrome login to
the system and can do many different
aspects of the data analysis and an ROI
selection there so what this shows on
the left is you have a technician that
the lab is running the instrument
they've loaded the samples they set up
the scans they then maybe notify the
pathologist it could be in another
building could be in another site within
your organization
they then select the regions of interest
and do the segmentation once that's done
they can approve the ROI collection it
then goes about collecting the ROI once
the the technician has brought the count
data back in from the encounter people
can you know the principal scientist or
the biostatistician they can all log in
review the data they can all be
reviewing that data while someone else
is collecting another study so it's a
great platform for collaborative
research where you know you have a
technician you have a pathologist you
have an oncologist you have a
biostatistician they can all collaborate
really well to work within the platform
in terms of the content so we've put a
great deal of effort into building out
really useful validated content and just
to give an example in the upper left on
the protein side what we've done is
we've built in immune cell profiling
core so this is a twenty marker core
that has all the positive and negative
controls and it has all the things like
C 3 and C D 68 and CD 45 and sort of the
the regular players they are in the
immune system and then you can select
different modules that you want to run
with that so we have a pan tumor module
and in the Intel typing module an immune
activation status and IO drug target and
we continue to expand these modules but
importantly you can add custom content
so if you have an IEP validated antibody
it could be an antibody that's very
proprietary to your research your drug
target that's fine we can put a unique
DNA barcode on it validate it and then
spike it into the panel so you can add
custom content as well on the right is
the RNA F is the spatial RNA which is
really a large focus of today's
discussion so we really just dipped our
toe in the water here we have an 84 gene
immune pathways core and that is focused
on human i/o it looks at things like
immune respond as well as that 18 gene
tumor inflammation signature that I
discussed at the very beginning in the
Merck paper in an you can add custom
content to that as well so one of the
expansions and flexibilities of the
platform is it if you recall you
collected those DNA barcodes into a
plate you can hybridize those to the
encounter barcodes and analyze them on
the encounter but you can also take
those and make sequencing libraries and
and what that does is it creates more
flexibility and enables more discovery
type applications so you're able to
increase the numbers of analytes that
you want to look at in this case we are
designing an initial panel of about 15
other genes and the content is drawn
from our very popular pan-cancer pathway
panels that are shown here
you
so again the platform allows you in this
case we're looking at protein dating
again to really understand the
heterogeneity of the tissue so in the
top left this is lymphoid tissue we've
selected different regions of interest
based on the staining of CD 3 CD 20 a
b-cell market and psi de keratin and you
can see looking across the x-axis the
different analytes looking across the
y-axis the different regions of interest
and you can see that the extensive
heterogeneity of expression across the
tissue and how similar regions cluster
together the same is true on the right
in colorectal cancer
so we have RNA profiling we have protein
profile we can actually do both of them
in that case what we're doing is we're
using serial sections so we're doing 40
proteins on one section and then looking
at the same exact regions of interest so
registered regions of interest we're
looking at the expression of 84 RNAs and
this is a small study in colorectal
cancer here with stain lip and side of
keratin cd45 and cd32 guide where in the
tissue we want to select these regions
of interest as well as the architecture
looking at the invasive margins and so
forth if there's on those serial
sections with ro eyes placed essentially
in the same location we segment it and
into tumor in strumice you can see that
in pink and green
and then we can look at the expression
of both the RNA and the protein and so
these are shown in two different heat
maps here where if you look at the top
bar there in the green and then the pink
you can see how the tumor segments
cluster largely together in the stromal
segments cluster together kind of turn
90 degrees you see the same with the
protein interestingly you do see some of
the tumor segments that cluster more
with the stroma and when we went back
and looked at those right those were
actually highly infiltrated tumor
regions so they had a lot of those sort
of stromal and immune markers within
them which causes them to cluster hope
to look almost more like stroma
so with that NGS readout capability we
can really start to look at some
hundreds and thousands of genes
spatially expressed and what this allows
you to do is to look for example if you
look at the bottom two panels here we're
doing spatial analysis and we're looking
at two regions of the invasive margin in
looking at these pathways and the active
activity of these pathways you can see
very different responses so on the right
you have sort of a very inactive
quiescent invasive margin and in the
left you have a much more active or
invasive margin so you can really start
to understand the biology understand how
these immune pathways are activated
which pathways are activated with
spatial context
so I'm going to turn this over to Chris
now and he's going to talk about
expanding the geo mix DSP capabilities
and applications with integrating the
RNA scope technology our big G Doug this
is Chris Merrett I am an RD Nana stream
technology so our goal was working to
expand the capabilities as Doug said to
geo mice and RNA scope and basically
combining these two strong technologies
together for one workflow so this is
just a cartoon a little image of the
workflow that we worked out so in the
end I've on the upper left hand corner
you can see the probes that we use for
our nesco that Anushka went through
those double Z probes we found that if
we hybridize those first in the workflow
like Auto stain and then move on to geo
mix DSP pros we got the best result
so the workflows laid out here where we
do RNA scope the first day geo mix DSP
Pro hybridization overnight into day 2
in the middle we do geo mix GSP on
through day 2 and then we do the
quantification on encounter on day 3 but
this is a really nice automated workflow
we had worked out so I'm going to show
some data showing how these two
platforms play well together so on the
left here what we wanted to look at
first was the RNA is our nice scoped
signal remaining the same when we add
geo makes RNA assays on top so these are
control cell pellets I've shown here
with three housekeeper controls so in
the upper section so I'm looking at the
left hand side which says RNA scope only
you can see bright signal green yellow
and magenta for the three target then to
the right where we do our nice coke plus
DSP RNA you can see similar signal
intensities below that there's a that be
negative controls again furnish grip
only you see no signal and not
surprisingly when you add tRNA on top of
it you no longer have signal so at a
high level the signal thing unchanged
which is great and so to the right we're
basically
the inverse is geo makes RNA signal
altered when we add RNA scope on top so
again this is just a really large field
of view of a mixed cell population and
basically the graph on the right shows
if we add RNA scope on top of genomics
PSP and compared to Jim CSP without RNA
scope we get indistinguishable results
so that was nice
so next thing we wanted to do is
basically bring it out of our model
systems and try this on tissues so first
I'm going to show some tonsil tissue and
on the left here are is an image of a
tonsil with 12 are lies that we've
profiled so these are the they're small
circles that you can see on the left and
then these are blown up in the middle
panel so we used RNA scope visualization
reagents CD 3e
which is in green and cd19 in magenta
and we also put a DNA dye on there which
is in gray so we use these Marni's scope
markers to actually help guide our our
wire selection so we if you can see in
the middle here you kind of see a blend
of CD 3 E and cd19 populations and then
on the right what I'm showing are some
correlation graphs of the DSP results
and the ACD results or the RNA scope
result um so in the upper right hand
corner where you had the magenta dots
I'm comparing to be some markers which
we'd expect to correlate so cd19 is on
the x-axis to cd19 RNA scope mean
intensity so I just pulled that right
off the DSP instrument to get the mean
intensity and then on the y-axis we
cd28 G omics DSP signal noise ratios and
what's really nice here is that when you
compare the two data sets from the same
tissue section you have a really high
correlation high r-squared value below
that in the green graph is CD 3 so this
is actually the same target that we're
going after so this is CD 3e again
bottom axis RNA skipping intensity
versus GM excuse psnr have a high
correlation of r-squared is 0.98 so that
was great in this tissue
second tissue we looked at was
non-small-cell tissue so again looking
at the exact same target cd19 and CD 3e
on the left you can kind of basically
it's a high-level view of this non-small
cell lung cancer tissue we went in and
profiled 12 ro eyes again for these
circles blown up in the middle and then
again we were basically for this
proof-of-concept experiment looking for
a mix of b-cells and t-cells so going on
the far right and the upper panel the
upper graph with the correlation again
looked at cd19 cd20 again really strong
correlation between the two platforms
and this is did again data on the same
section so in our square root of 0.98
and then if you go down below we have
the cd3 correlation which in general is
little less than CD 19 and cd20 but it's
probably mostly driven by the lack or
the very low proportion of t-cells in
the sample but again what was really
nice we can run both assays on the same
section get really nice data that
actually correlates quite well so moving
out of those model systems so now we
have confidence that these two assays
work well together we want to actually
move this into bio research in something
of more interest to the general
community so generation of immunity is a
difficult process that should on the
left here and what we're looking at is
we want to basically characterized the
cytokine expression and the tumor
microenvironment in these samples using
both of these technologies so on the
right we have a little workflow so our
we're going to use our wise selection
for RNA scope which I basically showed
in that in the last two slides and then
we'll do DSP analysis on top of it again
as i should't previously and then Anusha
is going to come in and actually show
some confirmation of G on mix DSP
results using RNA scopes so basically
going full circle with these two
technologies so this is the workflow
again to reiterate it lo Plex RNA scope
determine the regions of interest in the
middle we're going to do G omics DSP and
then confirmation so the first bit here
is the local x determine the
determination of regions of interest
so here's another nonce Mel Blanc in a
non small cell lung cancer tissue we're
looking at so this is different than the
one I showed previously so in this
sample we can profiled with cd19 or B
sub marker and p3e which is our T cell
marker and DNA just a guide selection so
in this case we actually profile 24 our
allies and then on the right there I
again zoomed in on these to show the
different kind of populations there in
the upper left around roi 136 you see
really strong expression of cd19 so
those are really rich for B cells as we
go down more towards like that bottom
row rear itch more for T cells or
basically are going after tumor regions
of very little immune cell content
so again these images were beautiful and
really helpful it actually guide the
selection on Geo makes DSP so what we
did not is we ran that experiment I just
showed there on the encounter system and
as Doug mentioned previously you get a
lot of data from this on the encounter
system so this is 84 genes from the i/o
panel and the names are too small but I
will all blow up some of these on the
far right at their gene names for all 84
genes on the left there again I'm just
keeping the image there for reference so
you looked at 24 are wise and those are
all listed along basically the x-axis of
this heat map of this cluster heat map
so I highlighted a few different regions
to cd19 and rich and mean poor and seedy
and three rich are wise and basically
what what I am showing here is these are
z-score a crossing and these are
basically clustered in an unbiased way
and you can see the immune for CDs to be
rich in some cd19 enriched our lives do
cluster together and then highlighting
some of the genes that were actually
seeing in these are lives if for the
cd19 enriched our allies we're getting
the characters we'd expect so the HLA
cd40 Ms for a1 which is C g20 and then
CD 74 and other targets and then on the
far right I'm showing I'm highlighting
from the CD 3 and rest are alive
expressor so cd4 cd8 expected ctla4
digits the use of e Fox p3 v si R which
is Vista in lags 3 so that gives us a
lot of confidence that were actually
profiling these appropriately with GSP
and then I also finally highlighted in
that in the box right in the middle in
the immune poor ROI is that large blue
square of just low expression and that
again these are our OIS we're basically
there very few immune cells that we
could see based on our visualization
with RNA scope and again blue is
basically very low expression as we'd
expect there
you
now so for the last step we actually
went in and confirmed some of the
results with RNA scope so I'll hand it
off to Anushka get over that
thank you Chris as Chris very nicely
explained our list code to use to
initially identify the cd3 which versus
the cd19 which regions in the lung
cancer tissue followed by which RDSP
analysis provided a very extensive gene
expression profiles for 78 targets in
multiple otherwise as Chris said this is
a lot of data and in this last test what
we do is this article can provide truly
single-cell resolution we can use our
Lascaux to confirm expression of a
handful of target genes that you might
be interested in so we can really hone
in on specific regions of interest and
confirm the expression of genes that
might have functional significance while
providing spatial orientations in your
tumor tissue so
out of the 24 otherwise that were
assessed by DSP - next we compare to
gene expression profiles between two
ry-ry 11 and otherwise 6 and variegated
the expression of a few genes that are
significant in amino quality research as
you can see on the screen roi 6 is a
cd19 glitch other line whereas otherwise
11 predominantly is a CD 3 which are
right now the genes of interest that we
selected for conformation are
significant in the cancer community
psycho I am sure all of you are familiar
with this cycle with the risin success
of amira therapies in recent years there
is a need more than ever to assess the
different cell types involved in
regulating this cancer immunity cycle
these include cells that reduce the
ripple factors like cytokines and
chemokines which promote and activate T
cells they have twenties and
collaboration and also migration on to
each item inside so some of the targets
that we pick include CCF 5 which is a
chemokines secreted by 10 T cells CX c
l9 which again is a chemo file that
attracts dendritic cells and other users
to the exchange site interferon gamma a
cytokine secreted by activated t-cells
another in yourself and cd8 which is a
marker of the effector T cells
so
onion article analysis on these four
targets in a cereal section of lung
tissue you observe that all these four
genes were expressed at a very high
level in the ROI 11 and this is exactly
what we expected since ry 11 is preceded
three rich region but having said that
we do see some basal level of expression
in the cd19 which otherwise otherwise
six now let's focus on the right-hand
side top panel which shows your
magnified image of the ry 11 but here
you can really appreciate the
single-cell resolution provided by our
let's go
the cell box with the blue arrow is a T
cells that secrete CXC and nine PCL 5
and response for cd8 so this is
potentially as active T cell just trying
to be secrete cytokines and activate
other T cells in its vicinity one of the
most important things I feel to take
from this slide if the correlation
between the DSP data that is shown in
the graph in the bottom panel and the
scaling of RNA scope for these four
targets and this really tells you that
both these techniques have concordance
and can synergistically be used in a
workflow to spatially map gene
expression in addition to analyzing some
of the activation ease we wanted to look
at some of the minimum regulatory
targets which are common targets for
currently popular immunotherapy now
these targets include ctla-4 cd1 which
are illiterate or e receptors on T star
and CBL one which acts as a ligand for
the shift vector we also looked at ICON
energy which is again a ligand for
co-stimulatory receptors
again in this image you see all these
four target genes probe together on a
serial section you can see the staining
very dramatically fastest in the city
three which are white eleven but you
also see moderate staining in receiving
ideas which are wide which tells you
that these cells eye cells definitely
present in both the otherwise but at a
much higher level in the cd3 which are
wide again the concordance between the
GST data and the early scope training
data is critical which is seen on the
graph in the bottom panel and in the top
right panel again a magnified image of
the roi 11 really highlights the PD one
positive ctla4 positive T cell that you
can see so comparing the gene expression
profiles of some functionally relevant
genes with its different region of
nitrogenous tissue you can identify
potential biomarkers that can really
help stratify patients and perhaps
predict the new SNP response so what
have you done today with this joint
workflow what we have shown you is that
we can visually map gene expression
using RNA scope and identify focused
regions of interest in a tissue
next we can obtain a gene expression
profile for focused areas using zoom
xtxt and finally for a handful of
regions of our hands of genes of
interest that you are cornered on we can
visualize specific targets in the tissue
with morphological context and
single-cell resolution using RNA scope
so with that we know that G Olmec stick
speed and our age group are individually
very powerful techniques but with the
choice workflow we can have spatially we
can have spatial gene expression profile
with high texting capability while
retaining the most logical context which
is extremely significant for
heterogeneous tissues or officials like
those two
especially lung cancer tumor and with
virtual workflow we have combined the
best capabilities of 40 technologies
while maintaining technical feasibility
for each process acting so with that I
will thank all of you for your attention
and we will take any questions at this
month
you
Thank You Anushka dog and Chris for your
informative presentations we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for okay
let's get started
our first question is what is the
spatial resolution of the geo mix
sequencing if thanks Michelle this is
Doug I'll take that one
so the platform using the DMD the
mirrors allows you to really shine the
light down to very small features within
the tissue you can certainly shine the
light down to an individual cell it
really depends on the application of the
platform and the research interest that
you have and the sensitivity of the
particular markers you're interested in
so it's more common that people look at
very specific cell populations within
distinct spatial regions of the tissue
Thanks
thank you all right your next question
can high-techs RNA scope be used as geo
mixed morphology markers
hi thanks for the question right now the
high flex is available for fixed and
stretched through the sample and so we
recommend using our multiplex approved
for ROI detection with Jerome X right
now
thank you okay your next question can we
use more than two genes for the ROI
selection
thanks to the question are yes we can do
up to three genes for our wide selection
as the first step in this workflow
thank you
okay well we're getting so many great
questions okay next is let's see how
many targets can be analyzed at a time
using the Geo mix DSP
yeah so as I was talking about earlier
with the capability of the next-gen
sequencing readout we haven't actually
found the limit we certainly looked at
over 5,000 distinct dish probes and been
able to very accurately quantitate that
large number of genes so we have not
found the roof and you know with
sequencing capacity it's certainly quite
high
q on on an average how many BP long is
each Z probe
hi so absolutely poop can bind to around
18 to 25 base pairs on the target so on
an average I would say 35 40 to the
group so 50 for a pair
you
thank you okay your next question what
kind of message is to validate your RNA
scope data
hi can you repeat the question sure what
kind of method you use to validate your
RNA scope data
so if you want to assess the specificity
of the steering you can use a positive
and negative control which are specific
probes that you provide with the gifts
and that way you can really discern
between specific and nonspecific
staining
you
thank you okay see next question see
we're getting so many great questions
okay is RNA scope of tissue
non-destructive technology
yes it does not destructive tissue when
you prove good re-scope it is
non-destructive so there's our tissue
will remain intact at the end of the
acid
you
thank you okay
question how many tissue slides of the
Geo mcsim hold at one time it holds four
slides at a time so you load four slide
scanner select ro eyes
collect and then you load the next set
of slides and you can do multiple sets
of slides in a day
Thank You next question could you
identify the RNA scope intramural clonal
population of t-cells yes
you can actually use our base coat as a
witch like I mentioned it specifically
designed to identify hydrogen one of the
sequences and that way you can have or
specific CDR or descends at the probe
that we can design and discern different
criminal population using our base coat
acid
great thank you okay next question can
our day scope be combined with
immunofluorescence for the validation
step well yes we can combine articles
dealing with the little person and we
have this joint work flow deck node
available on our website as well this is
a method that's very popular and a lot
of our customers use it often for their
research
thank you how is SNR from geomat
different than the normalized counts
generated from typical and pepper output
yeah I can take that question
so the SNR is different from the typical
encounter output so just based on time
constraints we didn't get through all
the details of the RNA si but within
that the 84 plexi gene i/o panel we
actually put in six negative control
probes along with the 84 so those are
basically like alien or scrambled
sequences just and measure the
background that we get for typical probe
so we use those just porn see - the
background is very different than a
normal and solution hybridization like
encounter so use that as the background
measurement and SNR's basically the
counts we're getting from say CD 3
divided by the average of those negative
control counts
great thank you all right next question
can be a CRNA scope be used to detect
mRNA or DNA with a hot gene or the
hotspot gene mutation and a specific
cell type in a tissue section
so all right y'all go ahead down your
scope okay I was just going to say that
as long as you can so if you can
fluoresce the target of interest using
in this case RNA scope then we can use
that to guide the cells in which we
analyze with DSP
so there's go maybe the question is
partly about detecting point mutations
fluorescently
yeah so I was going to say that the
articles we can actually detect DNA but
we can detect mRNA targets and for
specifically for mutations we encourage
using a scope which is thermogenic and
all sources itself
so you can validate your target
expression but not use it for our wide
selection
thank you I'd like to once again thank a
misfit Doug and Chris for their
presentations do you have any final
comments for our audience
as Michelle mentioned feel free to reach
out to any of the our emails on the top
of the page there that you're looking at
now and we'd be happy to answer any
additional questions you have we also
have a link to our joint white paper
that we published a couple of months
back and that is available on both of
our websites and the links are provided
on the slide
I'd like to once again thank our
speakers for their time today and their
important research we would also like to
thank lab herbs and our co-sponsors
advanced cell Diagnostics and nano
string technologies for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their questions questions we did not
have time for today and those submitted
during the on demand period will be
addressed by the speakers via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration laberd's will alert
you via email when the webinar is
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye
thank you